welcome back to the join us this week
this week it's a little underwhelming
after the debby machinist quite a high
to a low this episode is brought to you
by texture texture is a way to read
magazines without the magazine is pretty
incredible half it's a service you can
get in the computer and basically you
pay a subscription and you get tons and
tons of magazines at your fingertips
there on your device until for offline
reading it's really great I'm telling
you texture is the future of magazines
go to texture calm / energy right now
and get your free trial test it off free
it's also brought to you by new undies
me undies is the most comfortable
underwear in the world and also the best
looking check it out with me undies
dot-com / Jenna Julian 20% off your
first order and and if you order by
December 13th it'll be here by Christmas
so thank you to our sponsors more on
that later
yeah thank you guys appreciate it so I
had the idea that we should really talk
about this sand pepper issue so those of
you that like our funny light-hearted
conversations this probably isn't the
one for you but for those of you that
don't know who Sam pepper is a a quick
Google search I think will clarify who
we're talking about he's a former big
brother' contestant I'm sorry
and he's also a youtuber now and I was a
youtuber he's become quite controversial
in his last videos I think the most
controversial of which is that he makes
prank videos so sometimes the nature of
those is that people just try and 1up
themselves and a lot of them are fake
but he was also seriously accused by
multiple young women of either raping
them that that were he got accused of
that a few times sexually assaulting
them or harassing them and many of the
young girls were underage and he was
trying to get them to send nude pictures
um just all around sort of acting really
inappropriate he's been in the news as
of recently because he posted a prank
called
murdering my best murdering your best
friend prank was killing best friend
yeah so he collaborated with a couple of
minors and they were best friends from
Kansas and he pretended to kidnap and
murder one of them in front of the other
one and the Internet is pretty pissed
off at Sam pepper right now yeah um keep
in mind that we this isn't one of those
podcasts where we sat down beforehand
and wrote out our thoughts this is
completely off the off the cuff we're
just talking right now and yeah two days
ago about it came out new sites have
been talking about it there's been I
mean on YouTube itself you can't go on
YouTube without seeing it right now
everyone's making their reaction video
and and whatnot
although I roll my eyes at that but not
at age three eighty two productions
that's what he does best and he
absolutely did a great job on that I
roll my eyes of that because you know
you see something like this happened and
then every youtuber you know turns on
their camera and reacts and says the
same exact thing but in a sense it sorry
I'm kind of deviating right away but
it's a little frustrating just just to
see you know all these people who are so
disgusted and so put off by the way Sam
pepper acts and this prank and how
distasteful a is but they're not they're
not hesitating more than a second to
cash in on it and I only say that
because these reaction videos like they
can they can react the same way just not
make a video out of it because you're
all you're doing is given him more
publicity all you're doing is feeding
the troll' of Sam pepper right now and
like I said there are a few exceptions
to this h3 to production being one of
them but I don't know if you saw you
know on YouTube but you googles and
pepperiness or you search Sam pepper and
it's just my reaction is hit pepper I
did not know it's it's it's a lot like
the you know his last prank last
controversial prank the one where he
touched girls yeah so he had a fake hand
and he
was asking girls for directions and then
with his real hand it was hidden in his
sweatshirt he would like grope their
butts when they turned around and that
had people up in arms but the same thing
and I'm just talking about something
small that I thought of I did not look
sigh yeah I mean it's just one of those
things where it's like well well what is
it you know are you disgusted and you
don't want this guy to succeed or you
want to use it to you know fuel a video
yeah I can understand if somebody
outside of the reaction world so we
talked about h3h3 that's literally his
channel he reacts to really problematic
people in a hysterical way but for
people they're just making a reaction
video why not just sit and you know make
a rant or tell your thoughts about it
well yeah I didn't wait a day wait 24
hours and see if you're still so
steaming enough to make a video that and
I don't even think you know they're so
steaming or angry about it they're just
like well I could put this up now a lot
of people watch it yeah well it seems
like there are some people on YouTube
that try and do something whenever it is
most you know topical and when it's at
the height of its you know controversial
miss that they feel the need to react on
it as capitalized so I mean in essence
yeah it is capitalizing off of it um I
did not realize that people were doing
that many reactions videos to it but you
know the first time around when this
happened with Sam I think that actually
yes so the first time it happened was
that prank to which then he made a part
two and a part three which was him
finally through the Arctic the third
part of the prank which was you know
thousands of men get abused every year
which clearly was just like an
afterthought he was trying to dig his
way out of this hole without having to
admit any fault or apologize but what I
think is interesting is several people
Philip DeFranco as always has a
completely level-headed response to this
stuff and my first reaction he's an
exception as well obviously my first
reaction was the same as filled Franco's
I went on Twitter I saw that Sam pepper
was trending
and the first thing that came to my mind
was like oh god here we [ __ ] Gaul
like he's gonna be doing really
inappropriate [ __ ] with girls you know
maybe hopefully got caught or something
something uh no it's a I murdered my
best friend prank and I was like well
you know what this is a small win
because at least he's not like harassing
any women which i think is a win so
props to you that's true that's it was
honestly what I thought I was like oh
it's just a you know a ridiculous prank
that is horribly and sensitive and not
right but like at least he's not at
least he might have grown a little bit
from when he got or at least he didn't
he didn't want up it you know I guess
how to answer this last prank of Sam
peppers didn't change my opinion of him
at all so it's like you thought he was
scum
he's still scum it's not I don't think
that him posting this from all of our
knowledge made him appear any worse it
just is so predictable at this point
that he you know has no boundaries
yeah terms of well right or wrong I mean
I don't know about I I think in a
certain way it made him appear worse hmm
and the reason I think that is just
simply because of the timing the whole
Isis theme of the video it's just it's
horrible taste education team stars
interview with them and then you know
swore up and down that it's just a prank
that they knew their friends they knew
their limits and they were really just
doing this and really didn't think would
be a big deal
yeah they doesn't think about the ISIS
implications or Paris or any of that I
think it that speaks to who they are as
people is that there's living inside of
their bubbles without ever questioning
themselves like hey is maybe now a bad
time to upload a video yeah so you know
yes
yes it didn't involve him you know one
upping his his actions with women and
that kind of thing but yeah this this
didn't this didn't keep him steady this
this absolutely knocked him down a peg I
think and you know the three the reason
this is such a big deal right now I
think partly is because of the theme of
the video and the time that is now and
the things going on in the world and
it's like yeah he's young and he's
kind of maybe naive to not think about
that before posting this video but that
bit of you know naivete is a big deal
it's a big deal in this situation so you
know I would say if it weren't so themed
that way if the the video didn't strike
such a chord with a lot of people in
that sense it would still be in bad
taste but it wouldn't be this big of a
deal I don't think and yes I agree a
hundred percent and I think that you
know as Phil DeFranco pointed out a lot
of people have pointed out you take
other people that do pranks that you
know in some area are much worse than
this have gone much farther than this
like Roman Atwood had recently posted
that video of pretending to blow his kid
up yeah and you know it dances along
this line of really like okay what are
we doing to entertain people and what
are we just doing to sort of exploit
people's fears and clickbait them into
watching this you know is this really a
prank who's getting pranked here is this
funny what what am i contributing to the
world by doing this and I think that yes
if someone else had posted this same
video there would be less of a reaction
than there is now but because it is Sam
pepper already attacked because he has
done so many controversial things in the
past I think it just comes from people's
like tiredness of him doing
inappropriate things on the internet
which this was the main reason I wanted
to talk about this today is because the
YouTube community our YouTube in general
the Sam had cross-checked with them that
this doesn't violate any of the terms of
the guidelines yeah it didn't they have
no reason to take the video down because
people were very adamant that he should
take it down and then there were you
know a lot of big youtubers a lot of
people that we're talking about in
signing the petition that said Sam
pepper should have to have his channel
removed from YouTube and I think this is
like a really really dicey gray area
right now for internet communities and
that you know we all have freedom of
speech and freedom of expression why me
pending on what country you're posting
from but at least in the United States
we have freedom of speech and freedom of
expression and maybe just because you
don't like something that someone else
posts if YouTube doesn't deem it you
know bad for the Community Guidelines if
they can't they can't find a legal
ground to rip the video down it's sort
of a it's a gray area
you know who are we to be telling Sam
pepper like hey I'm signing this
petition to get your channel taken down
because who are we to say what's what's
good content and what's bad content and
as you tubers and people that watch
YouTube and people that like YouTube we
have to police ourselves as a community
so on one hand you know it is
disappointing to see some bigger
youtubers being like yeah rip his
[ __ ] channel down I'm I'm signing
this petition like [ __ ] you Sam pepper
but on the other hand the only people
that are going to police what's okay and
not okay to put on the internet on
YouTube is ourselves so like I am a
little bit disappointed that people are
forgetting that you know our rights our
civil liberties are a thing and that you
can't just rip someone's channel down
because you don't like what they're
posting but on the other hand I am proud
of people for speaking up and being
upset and being angry and policing
ourselves and that we have to make
boundaries of what we deem is
appropriate or not appropriate and I
think this has happened with Nicole
Arbour in the past and you know a couple
of other videos here and there but as of
recently there have been some really
sort of messed up videos that get
everybody really riled up and the
community all of a sudden is like take
it down like they shouldn't be able to
post that you can't say this stuff but
that is the price of freedom the price
of freedom is having to listen to other
people's opinions is having to know that
these people like Sam pepper can make
videos and that they exist and that they
really hit you in a place that you don't
like that's not right but I'm not
hundred percent sure that we should be
able to strip him of that liberty of his
freedom of speech and expression I mean
it gets into like technique
these so when you think about I mean
you're making really valid points but
when you think about like you know I
checked a couple hours ago 110,000
people have signed a petition to remove
his channel right well and it's just to
back what one second Laci green the
youtuber who does like she runs it as
sex and all that channel she had made a
petition back when he was harassing
girls and they were coming forward that
had over a hundred thousand signatures
yeah no no no I'm not yeah this isn't
the first petition option so over a
hundred thousand signatures on it um I
am obviously your freedom of speech
especially here where we know that's a
civil liberty is important and it's you
know everyone deserves it but until they
you know obviously break the law or
whatever but I'm not I'm not I'm not in
favor of the video being removed like I
don't think YouTube or anyone for that
matter has the right to say I'm
overriding this and I'm taking your
video down because that is stifling
freedom of speech what I what I do think
is fair is when enough people both when
the sexual assault you know video caused
an uproar and over 100 K signatures
happen and right now when this is
causing an uproar and 100 and Kasich 100
k plus signatures are on that petition
to remove his channel well not when I
see that many people both in the YouTube
community and fans of the YouTube
community which are also part of the
YouTube community and people outside of
it because you know those signatures
aren't primarily you know they're not
solely YouTube they might be primarily
do not solely YouTube people but when
it's that many people who are that upset
I think it's in YouTube's not only best
interest but it's their job to step in
and do something because there's having
unpopular opinions and polarizing
characters but then there's there's Sam
peppers recent video and I think that
there's a difference there's not you
know he's not just the bad guy he's not
just the guy that people like to hate
watch he's he's someone who has now
crossed the line for a lot of people and
have made YouTube feel
a little bit disgusting you know when
they watch this and you know as someone
who is part of it I feel like if YouTube
just you know does nothing in this this
channel is unaffected and it's six
months later he does another crazy thing
like I don't I don't think that's right
and I don't think as like I said as
someone who's on the platform it makes
me feel very good because then it seems
like I'm kind of like second handedly
supporting it right and you know you
really have to [ __ ] [ __ ] up to cross the
line the way you did and he did that he
really crossed the line and no in no
world do I think that should be allowed
to just like continue to happen you know
I'm not saying you take the video down
but I just don't think he should have
the free rein to continue to do so a AKA
have a perfectly unaffected Channel hmm
no I I wouldn't disagree with that and I
think you know what I was saying earlier
about the people in the community being
the only ones that can police what we
deem appropriate not appropriate I think
if YouTube were to step in and say you
know you guys have a lot of signatures
on this petition you know maybe we
should do something about this if you
take down one video that people don't
like that leaves the floodgate open for
everybody but it's not taking down one
video you're like it's it's a guy who
has had a second offense on massively
offending people to a really
uncomfortable standard removing his
channel or doing something to him it's
not the video the video lives all right
you know the video you can't touch the
video because you're right it's an
important thing to not stifle the speech
directly you stifle the person in a way
you know you give him
it's a privilege I'm sorry it's a
privilege to have a YouTube channel
that's why there are strikes and that's
why there are banned channels that's
what this is for like this guy has
proven himself to not know how to
properly make youtube videos that don't
piss off a hundred thousand people but I
mean my argument to that would be there
are troll channels that exists
with people full of unpopular opinion
puffins that literally just want to sit
there and piss people off
yes channels exist they they have
thousands more dislikes than they could
ever have in likes if somebody was just
upset enough you don't think that they
could get a hundred thousand signatures
to get every single video or YouTube
channel pulled off the internet where
those exists and now you're really like
bordering the the First Amendment you
can't take that away from here's how I
see well what what would you want
YouTube to do to Sam pepper hold on let
me respond first because here's how I
see the difference in those two
situations the difference is Sam pepper
has millions of young mostly female
impressionable kids and teenagers that
he's won their fandom like he already
has an insane following so when a guy
like him takes that following and you
know goes rogue and abuses the power he
has that's a scary thing I think that's
what people are so upset about it's like
someone I think in a legality sense you
it's not on YouTube's hands because even
if so for example and the last thing
happened with him harassing young girls
you know magically his Facebook and I
think the Instagram got you know quote
hacked but people are saying you should
probably just deleted them because
there's too much evidence in there of
him just acting so inappropriately with
young girls you would see it he didn't
hide it so if you take the platform away
from the person it doesn't change the
way the person is going to act no but it
does it does affect their reach and it
does affect their power but as someone
that I believe he hasn't been convicted
of a crime or done anything wrong
according to the YouTube guidelines or
Twitter's guidelines or Instagram
Facebook it's hard legally to take any
platform away from him it's it seems
like no matter what gets deleted of his
or where he gets shuffled around because
you know people are upset at him he will
always have
as long as he's you know free to do
whatever he wants on the internet he
will always have access to young girls
and they're impressionable minds because
there are people that are genuine fans
of his and really like him they will
find him so I'm not a hundred percent
sure what even taking down his channel
might do yeah I mean I when you asked me
that question what do you think
YouTube's you do I don't know like I
don't know I just know that if I'm part
of YouTube like go on the business side
I'm thinking this is making us look
horrible
well I agree with this and allowing it I
agree I'm not saying I know the solution
though because alright it's a
complicated situation it's very very
common well that's like you know Mark
Zuckerberg stepping in at somebody's
Facebook post that has an opinion that
they don't like or shows they think show
those terrible awful pictures of animal
abuse on Facebook that you scroll
through your feet and they're just
they're like they I think that platforms
have some responsibility of cleaning
things up so that you can't just see the
horrific things that people post which
is why guidelines exist for different
platforms but all they can do is really
adhere to what they've written there and
everything else they have to let go
because otherwise you're infringing on
people's freedom of speech so that I was
just a little bit upset when you know
the petition was going around to remove
his channel I think it should be heavily
weighed on YouTube I think that people
there I have definitely thought about it
they're definitely thinking about he got
dropped by his network a long time ago I
think the people within the industry
have already made it very clear that
we're not going to work with him or you
know do stuff I can't speak for the vine
community because those two Viners were
clearly willing to work with him but all
we can do as a community is sort of
socially say that this isn't acceptable
that we're not okay with this because we
know legally there there's not a lot of
grounds there yeah even with the sexual
harassment prank I think it came out
that those girls were actors anyways
wasn't it
uh yeah I don't know I just I know that
no like I know that he you know the
second and third video or like oh this
was all fake they were paid after but
doesn't Chami it doesn't change it for
me like right but okay but what I'm
saying is even if that video was living
breathing proof that he was sort of
harassing girls in public and somebody
could arrest him on some charges for
doing that and then he says these are
paid actors that you know negates all
reason for someone to arrest him so I
don't think that you can convict him as
of the current moment are you right
you're I'm not saying you can convicted
and you know what maybe you do but maybe
you you're onto something when you say
something you know along lines of like
to you know let him dig his own grave
and let the YouTube community shot him
yes that that was one of my my bigger
ideas here within the YouTube community
is that it's not our responsibility to
say that someone can or can't upload
content I think it's only our
responsibility to do what we can as a
community which is sort of get him the
message that you can't post this and
this isn't okay and we're upset about
this and hopefully that's enough for you
to grow up and move on which clearly
it's not for Sam pepper it's not our
responsibility to make sure that his
livelihood ends it's not our job to rip
his YouTube channel from him to strip
him of his liberties he needs to do that
for himself by you know committing a
crime and going to jail yeah it's what
he did in this video was not a crime
well no I think I'm just realizing is
that it's just unfortunate because it's
disheartening yeah it's just it's one of
the situations where like you want a
quick fix and you want justice but it's
a little more complicated than that
don't think of all the people in history
that have gotten away with crimes and
they just continue to live their lives
if you literally get away with [ __ ]
murder yeah but and you want so badly
for this person to get the justice but
they that they deserve but you know
better that it's not your job to make
them you know [ __ ] up or do something
wrong they they will eventually dig
their own graves and pay the price
yeah and what you said about the YouTube
community shunning him and like if if
that continues to that you know the
scape of how YouTube react to reacted to
Sam pepper if that if that continues on
the trajectory like people just hate him
more and more every time he does [ __ ]
like this like he he's gonna slowly just
get kind of phased out right well that's
what I think if there was a petition
going around because it was started by a
young girl I think who you know I
imagine she was like yeah if I just
start this week let's just see how
people we can get and hopefully maybe
you should will rip their Channel down
but maybe a 13 year old person that
starts the petition doesn't really think
about someone's civil liberties and how
you can't just you know take away
certain things when they're not
violating any particular guideline it's
not possible what I think should have
been circulating amongst the YouTube
community is maybe a petition to never
work with Sam pepper yeah blacklist him
from our community because it was
disappointing to see young Viners and
other people collaborating with him when
in theory if we blacklist him from our
community like you're not invited to
VidCon you're not invited to events
you're not like able to work with any of
us in any capacity until you clean up
your channel and show that you're
growing as a person like that's through
session that should be going around
there's a lot to be said for that if if
people are really that upset and that's
a 12 person's discretion if they'd like
to sign a turn I I agree with you and I
think there's a lot to be said about
what you just said I think that's you
know realistically the way to go and the
way it's all that we have control of yes
it's it's realists Louie way to go it's
what we have control over and it you
know it's it's the natural order of
things in our society that's how it has
to happen apparently we don't know that
that's what it appears to be but no man
I just lost my train of thought um yeah
I mean the the row here it is yeah the
reason like the that petition whoever
started it the fact is a lot of people
signed it and I think the reason a lot
of people signed it and the reason it's
getting attention and all this and the
reason it was even started is
because people are offended they're
disgusted this isn't the first time and
they want they want a quick fix they
want the most and then when somebody to
do something about it
but they want they don't want to have to
they don't want to be like alright
here's a petition to slowly phase him
out and everyone has to slowly get on
board and never work with him and then
maybe in a year or two he'll be gone
like people wanted like no [ __ ] his
channel take it down now they want they
want immediate reaction so that's why I
think that petition exists not to say
it's reasonable or even lawful I don't
know the answer to that but I think you
know it's justified why people acted
that way of course um but you know what
you said is uh it's it's a really good
point and uh you know it really it's one
of those things where it's like you know
in a professional sports league if the
players aren't being treated right they
form a union and then things are better
like there really needs to be a union
formed around creators to just not I
mean not only Sam pepper
especially Sam pepper but not only him
like this kind of [ __ ] is not going to
be someone I'm going to in a year when
people have calmed down on him
collaborate with I'm just never going to
do it it needs to be something that the
big creators and then the medium
creators and then the smaller creators
all agree on you know
did she that's what YouTube is so what
we it then again you know we're being
open to the fact that we may be wrong
right now I mean like you don't know a
lot we also as people need to be open to
the fact that sometimes people you know
are kind of shitty for a time but they
can grow and learn and change as human
beings because they are human beings I
think at some point everyone sharing
things online has reached a point where
maybe they shared something that they
thought was in a big deal and it became
a big deal because people were like wait
I don't like this on any scale I think
that everyone has experienced that at
some point like me it whether it be like
oh my god don't feed your dog that or
you know stupid up and to vary offenses
but what I think is important is that
you don't like drag these people through
the mud for forever which I think the
internet is really good at they they
tend to just hold people accountable
something that they did like that vine
of you know nash grier whoever saying
something inappropriate about aids yeah
and you know tyler oakley dragged him
and then people were very angry at nash
and he was like look i was like 13 when
i posted that for super sorry i defeated
you're absolutely right support
absolutely right that if you rips down
Sam peppers video and channel where
whatever he's put on the internet that
doesn't solve any well you know I agree
I agree and people shouldn't drag people
forever you know people change and right
people deserve second chances in all
this [ __ ] but uh you know what about
lucky your suspension like you can't
upload for a year like what about that
that seems like something that a they
could pull and be would at least sort of
satisfy people like HM where would you
draw like so say your YouTube think
about it from YouTube's perspective
because videos get flagged and just you
know disliked take for example Justin's
be Justin Bieber's music video for baby
has over five million dislikes yeah
five million dislikes I'm pretty sure
when that song came out because of the
way that people felt about Justin Bieber
you could easily get a petition with a
million people that signed it that said
take this video off the internet yeah if
your YouTube where now do you draw lines
and make rules as a community about who
you're going to put on probation or what
you're going to remove outside of their
already pre written guidelines how would
you justify taking down someone's
content versus someone else's because I
think if your YouTube or Google you're
in a whole ton of hot water if you start
subjectively just removing things from
the internet because that person can
turn around and just sue you well then
you're in a situation where there's a
court case and that will change things
and maybe that's what needs to happen
you know Sam pepper versus YouTube
changes it so from now on things did
happen this way will you know subject
your channel to one year two year three
year ban you know I'm saying like maybe
it does need to go to court how-how-how
I don't know if I'm used YouTube go
about making the decision of who gets
banned okay what I'm looking at right
now is I'm looking at the choices you
get when you click flag on it
there's sexual content violent or
repulsive content right I mean these are
reasons for flash yes flag and it's not
flat yet like the video I mean it's not
dangerous trick to door anything hateful
or abusive content harmful or dangerous
acts child abuse and fringes my rights
spammer misleading and then playback
issue so the YouTube made those Google
did created those categories those are
they've also the guidelines so those are
just no I know that's just a simple flat
obsidian absolutely so if people see a
video and they think well this applies
to that directly like say you know I
think that applies to that directly
YouTube has I mean that video has been
flagged it's God have been flagged tens
of thousands of times and it's still up
so why are these choices here when I
would look at them and say yeah those
those are right to flag on this video
and yet somehow the video is not
restricted well let me ask you a
question to play devil's advocate if
this video was flagged and taken down
why isn't Roman Atwoods blowing up my
kid we're a district two flags are taken
down very restricted if Sam peppers
groping people in public video was
flagged or taken down then why aren't
all those gross noisy kissing pranks
well we don't you don't know like no yes
but I'm responding like we don't know a
what the tipping point is for this like
if your YouTube you know but we don't
know how many flags it takes to actually
flag a video we don't know that we also
don't know how many flags each of those
videos you just mentioned gone right
well I believe that if people flag a
video yeah YouTube does when it gets
enough flags YouTube don't win that's
enough though I don't I'm not cheap as a
general like you say enough flags but
Sam pepper definitely got red flags no
no no no when you get enough Flags
YouTube does go in there so they have
someone watch it and deem whether or not
this needs to be age restricted so just
just getting our facts in and of itself
doesn't necessarily Naqvi so like if you
uploaded a video of somebody getting
murdered on the street and like even
five people flagged it I'm sure at some
point YouTube go I know this that
YouTube goes in
to believe in checking the video yeah
and yeah and either deletes it or rips
it down to decide if it violates the
Community Guidelines in any way which
means copyright in music you know if
it's gratuitous discussing violence or
if it violates the actual guidelines
they will rip it down and if it needs to
be age restricted then they do that in
that process but just because millions
of people dislike it and flag it does
not necessarily mean it's going to get
ripped down or age restricted they make
the decision like solely based on if
it's infringing on copyright if it's you
know not following the guidelines and
that's about it hmm
well yeah I mean I don't know like it's
just it's just a complex kind of thing
you know I I didn't I don't I'm not
saying I thought that if enough people
clicked a button the video would
automatically turn off like I know
there's a team people but you know that
that literally means it's a case-by-case
basis you know each video has a
different well if people are flagging
something they do have somebody that
goes and checks it out but no matter how
discussing you might find it as a person
if it makes you feel a certain way if
it's not violating the terms of use you
can't take it down if it's violating the
terms of you know being age restricted
or not they can turn that on I mean I
think there's an argument for this video
being age restricted I certainly
wouldn't want you know a little kid I
was baby supposed to shooting on YouTube
for speaking on that yeah of course but
I mean if that's restricted then
everything else is [ __ ] age
restricted not true not true
because just because a video has content
that shouldn't be seen by kids doesn't
mean it should be age restricted it's
it's Sam pepper like it's the caliber of
Sam pepper that presents such a big
problem here right but because he hasn't
been convicted of a crime not sale I'm
not saying you're wrong I'm just saying
that's what makes it different no I
understand but just because we know who
he is as a person and what he's done in
the past been accused of in the past
and him being problematic on the
internet doesn't necessarily come into
YouTube's decision whether or not to
leave his channel up or this video up
but what I do think is interesting and
something to think about is that there
have been people on YouTube that have
been charged and convicted with
possession of child pornography they I
forget his name I think his YouTube
channel name was David Farms I literally
just googled this before we started he
had been convicted of inappropriately
touching kids doing a bunch of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] in like 92 Tillich went to jail
came out started a YouTube channel aimed
at children what is aimed at children
Michael Vick his audience good show got
it and unfortunately I don't I don't
know what happened to him or if he still
exists I don't have that much on Google
it please google it if you're interested
in it and let me know what happened but
he had a YouTube channel aimed at
children and was a convicted sex
offender like where where is the legal
area there I don't know that's too much
so I think what's dangerous and why
people are really upset not this
particular video is out of it but with
the rape allegations and the sexual
harassment allegations against Sam
pepper and he continues to be able to
have a platform to reach and directly
talk to young girls is really bad but
unfortunately we can't do anything about
it you don't know that what can we but
we don't know but that statement we
don't know it's true what we can't do
anything about it what she do everyone
can but on but we can speculate all day
long but the point is we don't know we
don't know what YouTube is capable of
hmm we just don't we don't know what
they can find in the law that allows
them to do certain things you know we
just don't know it doesn't look good
because it seems like it'd be infringing
on our rights but we don't know I think
it's really important to remember that
we just don't know I just think that
it's scary that he will always have
absolutely it's [ __ ] it's nice Cory
ensues he has access to stole from it's
just sad takes away someone's ability to
use social media unless they're in jail
oh it's sad okay but you know
I don't know I think the speculating on
what what can be done is just a little
useless I think talking about what we
think should be done realistically what
are you okay so in a perfect world what
do you think should be done
I like the suspension I like having him
suspended from YouTube for an extended
amount of time is it is he getting
suspended for this particular video or
as a body of his work you have to
believe that after the sexual harassment
prank video he had a talking-to from
YouTube well I know that he got dropped
from his Network okay
so you have to believe someone from
YouTube spoke with Sam pepper or his
people saying hey we can't tell you what
to do we can't you know we have you have
your rights but don't do that again
don't you know don't [ __ ] do that
[ __ ]
they must have had some capacity of that
talk with Sam pepper I don't I mean I
just I view YouTube as a solid you know
well-oiled machine that you know does
things right for the most part I mean
obviously I don't know a lot but just
looking at it you'd think that that had
to happen so let's just say that
happened let's just say he got a nice
stern slap on the wrist after that video
this video happens from YouTube I say
okay we had that talk and you went and
you put it in our face and you made this
video and it's upset a lot of people
it's hurting our brand you are now
suspended for a year I mean I'm not
saying I know the law I'm not saying
that's legal or anything I just think
that that is you know the punishment
sort of fits the crime in a sense you
know it's something and it seems to me
that that's the most realistic
punishment that could be dished out at
this moment so you're saying from
YouTube's perspective
they don't like what he does two times
in a row and he gets his channel banned
and so is this according to the
petitions that were signed or is this
just according to people at YouTube not
liking his content no this is babe
YouTube's not liking its content this is
the people at YouTube looking at what
has the reaction of the world like it's
it's not about opinions anymore it's
about seeing what happens so by that
logic though then is Nicole Arbour
banned from YouTube as well no it was it
was different it was very different the
ISIS thing babe it's it's just that's
that's what's doing it for me it's like
you're saying if I'm YouTube what do i
do that's what I would do Nicole Arbour
was offensive she was right but she's
wrong are the same on the same scale she
got people riled up just absolutely
absolutely but you know what she was
trying to do that written I don't think
Sam pepper was also I don't think he was
trying to do I don't think II mean I
don't ya know this but this scale he
might have been trying to play the bad
guy but he did not expect this type of
outlash way just do this he's done like
saw pranks ya know he tried to kill his
friends in the past ya know he's [ __ ]
please don't do these stupid pranks like
in his brain this was mild in terms of
what he has done well no it's yeah I
think he's not ready for the backlash
but if you're if you're YouTube though
and you decide that this is disgusting
content why do you ban Sam pepper and
not Roman Atwood okay can we take a
quick second a sponsor's non-symmetric
this is no this is a good discussion and
I'm happy we're having it it's just one
of those that it's like what do you do
there's no clever segue here so there's
just I'm not going to do a segue it's
not appropriate but there's there's not
a lot of there's not a lot of like you
know hope or any any positive I can come
out of a discussion like this it's just
kind of like just talking about and
learning as we go
anyway this week's sponsor texture is
this is one of those things that in in a
few years
magazines won't exist I believe that
they're completely old right now and
texture is going to put them out texture
is it's an app on your phone okay
it's you go on website on your devices
on your tablets on your phones and you
pay a subscription for hundreds and
hundreds of magazines and these are
magazines that you have at your
fingertips not only do you just pick out
what magazine you like you know say you
like men fifty Men's Fitness whatever
not only that but the magazines you read
will you know trigger them to curate
different magazines that you might like
so already you have what you want but
then they're suggesting things that you
also might like that you would have
never picked up in a magazine stand
you're at the airport you're in a rush
you don't need to stop and buy a 10
dollar magazine you have it already paid
for by your monthly subscription on
texture or imagine if you like own a
salon or you run a scenario oh it's
brilliant you can I pad its customer
knocked a doctor's office you buy one
iPad you leave it in there you let your
clients just an internet hangout how
free magazine I mean think of that
that's the future no right magazine
subscription and not not to mention this
is incredibly green you're getting rid
of all those magazines like anyway
texture calm / jenna julie and gives you
your free trial and go check it out see
how you like it I've tried it it's great
I think you will like it to me on DS
okay so me on DS we've had sponsor
before they make some of the softest
material you can ever put on your body
it's called micro modal fabric and I
know that doesn't sound sexy but it is
incredibly set yeah it feels incredibly
sexy and they just released a new boxer
line which is just like wearing nothing
except better because you're wearing me
entities they have plenty of different
awesome designs colors styles to choose
from and like I said if you like your
Mia T's order by Christmas you order by
December 13th and you will get it by
Christmas they guarantee that also if
you are not happy they will return it
and it will give you a full refund which
is awesome me and these are great people
one more thing if you live in the US or
Canada you get free shipping which is
awesome so if you never had me undies
you can try it and you get 20% off your
first order trust me these are not your
mom and dad's stocking stuffers these
are dope
check it out at me on these that's MEA
undies comm slash Jenna Julianne and see
all the cool stuff that they have there
you will not be disappointed
yeah thank you sponsors thank you
sponsors for standing bias even when we
do hypothetical podcasts about what
could happen and what should happen they
believe in us they do I appreciate that
and they believe in freedom of speech
yeah I'm I'm that's why I'm very
thankful that I you know people have
fought and died for your ability to
speak your mind and it's something I
hold near and dear which is why I will
always play devil's advocate regardless
of how much I am NOT a huge fan of the
video that Sam uploaded or some of the
things that he does I do believe that he
should have the right to say what he
wants and create what he wants I think
it's important to have that mindset
because a lot of people forget that in
times like this they get up in arms and
nothing matters and they just you know
they don't think about implications of
human rights and stuff like that hmm
he did get threatened by anonymous yeah
it seems like keemstar debunked that
that was the first thing I did did you
check an update on that let me check
return but so last night around 10
o'clock we had read that anonymous was
threatening Sam pepper that if he didn't
take the video down but they were going
to unleash quote [ __ ] hell on him but
I had gone to the Twitter account is
called anon messages right and it wasn't
the one that I was following like I
follow a couple of them that seemed to
be relatively legit and I wasn't sure if
this was also one but it was for sure
last night the only one that was
mentioned mentioning anything about Sam
pepper and then I believe that keemstar
from dramaalert had reached out to like
a known anonymous Twitter account and
they had said we're not affiliated with
that account and you know Anonymous is
not going after Sam peppers it's not
within their interests so they're there
they've been attacking him hey you the
@v a non message on twitter has been
attacking Sam ever since nine
earlier tonight what they say well
they're doing things like a hashtag and
Sam pepper let's see so we found your UK
address we were in the middle of
pinpointing your LA address what are you
going to call it quits Sam pepper but
seriously though your sister I'm not
sure what that's referencing it's
probably a tweet of Sam peppers I think
well let's not wait till midnight
we're sorry Sam no way we're not hashtag
prank gone wrong hashtag and Sam pepper
and they boo they're quoting the this
address that might be his UK address oh
let's see
yeah your countdown is like 15 minutes I
was talking to keemstar he said uh-oh
they tweeted out his phone number
apparently this is alleged I don't know
anything and then they said answer the
phone damn it at Sam pepper so
apparently and then they said glad you
enjoy the show more to come we're just
not over we're not over with you Sam
pepper we're just beginning the world
has no place where rapist scum all right
but we did see on Team stars drama that
that is not an official a non account so
there could be that could be just a
small sect of current or former a non
yeah that may be is just kind of going
rope so we don't know just what he
deserves that but that's kind of a lot
so if you do go to that Twitter account
don't like the these guys I mean these
residences are fine you guys are dope
also you're going to be watching this
what five six days after a recording it
so it might have died down a little by
them there might be new developments by
the time you watch this actually yeah I
had like last night when I was very
interested in what was going on I went
to Sam peppers likes on his Twitter page
and he had liked a tweet from someone
that some said something along the lines
of you know youtubers always preach this
whole no bullying thing and then as soon
as Sam pepper makes a video that they
don't like they're the first ones to
bully Sam pepper I guess
as the tweet that he had liked and I
thought that was interesting I don't
think anybody's bullying him I think the
internet might be bullying him but I
don't know of any youtubers that are
bullying him but even if that was the
case it's an interesting idea to think
about and that just because someone
makes something that you don't like as a
community we need to find a common
ground of how we're going to police
ourselves but you know what does Dean
bullying or if if all of us are doing it
together is that bullying if if we're
doing it in a way that's not we don't
really know the outcome or might not be
a hundred percent constructive as a
bullying is you know saying our two
cents about what he made is that
bullying it's like it's [ __ ] gray
area all over the place do you think
anybody's bullying him the Internet's
bullying him I don't know I I don't know
I don't really think it's not bullying
that that account is bullying him you
can't
yeah but he's bullying the millions of
kids who he's earned trust and he's just
[ __ ] on the his platform that so
many kids who are young like it's so
much responsibility to have that bit fan
base and he's thrown all of it out the
window
all of it that's bullying in my opinion
you know if the alleged all the girls
that came trip through or came forward
about him a sexually assault if that's
true that's [ __ ] bullying that's but
you know some could call it rape or
sexual assault I'm sorry yeah he maybe
deserves a little online cyber bullying
at the moment right now because of what
he [ __ ] did bullying someone because
they have a different opinion you you or
they're different than you is totally
different than bullying someone who's
bullied millions and [ __ ] ruined
people's lives allegedly and really
pissed off a whole ton of people you
know some I mean I'm just not going to
like I'm not gonna sugarcoat it I like I
[ __ ] don't like the kid I think he is
just a perfect example of abusing power
and being someone who is so unequipped
have that power and like you know I've
seen the kid in person I've had one
interaction second hand interaction with
him and I hated it and I'm everyone I
talk to you as have the same experience
in it it's it's one of those things that
it gets me fired up because you know I
know that there's no quick fix and this
kid is going to just continue to do what
he wants and abuse his power until he
actually really [ __ ] up which he can be
careful about not to so it's one of
those things where I'm just like there's
not much to do you know he's for sure it
is disheartening but I think the the
best thing that we can do all that we
have control over is whether or not
we're paying attention to what he's
doing so you know for any parents out
there that don't really monitor with
their kids who are me on it maybe your
[ __ ] 12 year old is a fan of San
peppers like just try and pay attention
to maybe who they're following and what
that person stands for and what they're
about and be responsible for yourself
you know as much as I didn't want to
watch that video because I didn't want
it to count as you for something that
you know is pretty [ __ ] up I watched
it because they you know was trying to
pay attention to what was going on as
I'm sure a lot of other people did but
you know if you don't want to have this
conversation with your kid or your
teenager or you don't wanna have this
conversation with anybody that's a fan
of theirs maybe you should maybe you
should and maybe you should pay
attention to what your kids are watching
we as Watchers of the Internet should
pay attention to what we're watching and
making sure that we support people that
we think are real and you know don't go
behind our backs
as people that trust them and watch them
to you know take advantage of young
girls or do things that are really
messed up because I I don't I don't know
of any other youtubers that are doing
that that that go on Twitter and ask for
people to send them nudes I just don't
know people like that
and I maybe it's maybe they do exist I
don't know it's not a stretch of the
imagination that there are some men out
there that would love nothing more than
a bunch of young girls following them so
that they could pester them into meeting
up and
they don't know I don't know maybe they
[ __ ] do exist but I don't know of any
and since I know ever since that broke
about Sam pepper it just can't watch his
videos I can't justify sitting on and
that's doing your part you know like
yeah everyone does their part like you
were saying if a parent just monitor you
know if your kids watching us and
peppers just be aware be aware of things
like that right you know don't just
think it's all good because it's not
well that [ __ ] every because he does
have a solid fan base of people that
genuinely enjoy him okay if either
choose to see around the [ __ ] or
don't really and but there's there's one
thing I want to mention in it this
something that scares me more than
anything and it's that it's that young
impressionable part of his audience the
young that that feature of the demo that
watches the filth that he puts out is
like they will watch this video they
will watch the sexual-assault video and
be like [ __ ] first to defend him like
back off Sam pepper he's a great guy
heat in me like and they have zero
[ __ ] argument I'm sorry they've zero
argument not only do they have zero
argument but they are in zero place as a
thirteen-year-old girl to be arguing in
such argument I'm sorry that's that but
the that's that's the part where he's
abused such like important power like
he's won over these kids and so now
everything he does they will defend and
they'll blindly defend it so now you
have kids hundreds and thousands of kids
probably right now defending someone who
is as tasteless and you know made such a
disgustingly time video Sam pepper these
kids probably nah know what Isis is
either yet they're defending this
existence of this video like the whole
the whole aspect of young kids defending
a creator that they're really passionate
about through literally anything is
something that terrifies me it terrifies
me because what it is is it's the person
who is allowing that to happen you know
it's it's it's just so it's just so fun
I like don't want it unfortunately
there's nothing that you and I can do
about that except encourage people to
pay attention to what you're young
brothers your sisters your cousin's your
nieces your nephews your children pay
attention to what they're watching and
you as a person that has the ability to
see the whole scope of maybe what is
going on in that young person's mind or
life just have a talk with them you know
try and understand why they might be a
fan of someone's because his audience
genuinely does really enjoy him and like
him and he is a human being he's a human
being he's not he's not the worst guy
ever to exist like he has been good in
the past he hasn't always been this bad
also I I would like to say that this
whole like you know if somebody I'm
gonna make a vast over generalization
right now but I have seen on the
Internet if someone is accusing a guy of
like you know doing something completely
inappropriate harassing them there is a
tendency now on the internet to just
start calling them rapists
which I don't think is right either and
although Sam pepper has been accused of
Radiance well it's all alleged it's all
legit we all need to reportin yeah we
are we're being court of public opinion
he is has not been convicted of a crime
but if you're a parent or an older
sister or brother of one of these young
girls who clearly is watching him on a
regular basis and you know enjoying that
maybe you understand why and maybe just
talk to them about why some of it isn't
okay yeah and how and how maybe yeah
right the best way that you can help
these young people that really enjoy him
is to get them to think critically and
to make their own decisions about what
they choose to find entertaining why do
you find this entertaining a 12 year old
13 year old those are those are little
adults to me you can have a very deep
and thought-provoking conversation with
a young adult they know what's going on
they have great thoughts great opinions
and to know that some of them are taking
their really talented special minds and
being subjected and finding it enjoyable
is those kids need clearly need someone
to just have a conversation with
about it why did why are you watching a
video of a kid pretending to kill some
other kid's best friend why is that
entertaining gee what do you like about
this kid because if they can't give you
an answer other than oh I think he's
cute like maybe it's time for you to
step in as a parent or a brother or
sister and say listen up bro you're not
like you're not gonna watch the in
pepper and I watch you know because they
are young girls he is you know
contacting them or has in the past I
can't say that he continues to do that
but he has contacted young underage
girls in the past which is problematic
and we as human beings only have control
over what our loved ones are consuming
and to try and encourage them to make
good decisions about what they find
entertaining you know yeah I don't think
you're right like everyone know everyone
I know there's not very many you know
there's there's an older crowd they're
not like primarily 13 year olds but
there's an older crowd that watches the
podcast so when we say this here we we
know we're talking to right we're
talking to their older brothers all the
sisters this you know the adults who may
be have effect on kids who are that
Demone I didn't mean to say that every
thirteen-year-old who watches YouTube's
an idiot I didn't like I'm just saying
now there are those yeah I mean fandom
is a scary thing and when it's when it
happens when people extend pepper
manipulate audiences who are so easily
manipulated things can get really hairy
that's all I was trying to say but no
it's absolutely important to have an eye
on what the people who are young in your
life and who you love and who are
impressionable or what they're doing
online because you know it's nothing
like how we grew up you know they're on
their phone all all day long they're
consuming content without my permission
props to all the parents out there who
are doing the best that you can when
brothers and sisters because you can't
possibly monitor what that person
watches 24/7 it's impossible but I think
if you spend enough time with a young
person you can get a good understanding
of what they're into one episode I
learned so much when I talk to kids who
watch YouTube like
kill my step-brother like he liked
hearing from him is like is he turned
directly from the people like his age
who are young and watched videos I make
and Jenna makes and like I'm I need just
as much as like I know more than my
parents they know more than me it also
you learn a lot it's it's important to
keep your ears up and I've had hundreds
of conversations with parents being like
you know I caught my daughter watching
your videos and there was some language
but then I realized that like it really
wasn't that bad I'm not doing anything
horrific yeah I've heard that man great
you know at least within the last few
years my content has been relatively
tame aside from making an occasional
drunk video but even then she parents
have told me you know I'd rather have my
son or daughter watch you while you
swear or you know you talk about sex or
you've gotten drunk on camera I'd rather
have them watch that a million times
over then some of the other things on
the internet that are really not
appropriate for their age and because it
was a point of insecurity in security
for me for a long time that these young
kids were watching what I did and I
wanted to make sure I wasn't being like
a terrible person but you as a person
can't really control who's consuming no
you can't you just have to have a sense
of responsibility that's all it is
social response social responsibility
when you're online people are watching
you that's what you have to have yeah
that's what Sam pepper does not have had
the kind wouldn't disagree that he has a
level of social responsibility that is
almost non-existent and I think that's
scare me but they didn't control their
you can't control whether or not Sam
pepper cares that he's reaching these
young girls and doing things that is
sending me back well yeah and you know
like we I would like to see you guys
participate in a conversation in the
comment section but I don't want to see
you guys get heated and attack and
everything like that I know this was
kind of an intense podcast and it wasn't
a happy-go-lucky normal Jenna Julian
podcast but we we would like to hear
your thoughts on on kind of everything
and if you have something to say say it
try as best you can to be respectful we
obviously can't control what you say but
just like we can't control Sam pepper
but yeah yeah which I mean should there
be a punishment if somebody creates
something and lawyers of the Jenna
Jillian podcast family tell us what we
miss tell us yeah we're we're wrong or
right or you know if YouTube or a
platform did have the legality because
you know even Twitter there are people
within Isis that have twitter accounts
the tweet thousands of times a day it's
you know legal gray area that I'm not a
hundred percent familiar with but you
know what are your thoughts where does
the gray area start and begin for
YouTube if they were to start policing
content what should be the ramifications
so on so forth and also let me know your
thoughts about freedom of speech and if
you think this violates people's freedom
of speech and if taking down videos
violates people's freedom of speech
because I think as angry as the Internet
is and was and probably will continue to
be what I think is most important to
remember is that Sam pepper is a human
being he is capable a US citizen is your
citizen or is he is he's pretty sure
[ __ ] honest I'm sure he is capable of
growing and changing so you should treat
him like a human being I think it's
appropriate to you know treat him any
less than a human being and we don't
know that he's done anything wrong
yeah as of this current time ok well
let's let's you know
we define wrong we have opinions no hope
but the whole whole sexual assault thing
we don't know if any that's definitely
just we well yeah if you think about it
like you're in a jury right now can you
convict him no I don't know you didn't
break your he didn't break the law right
so as far as we know what I want though
is that for the people that listen to
this podcast and that interact with
other people in the future about Sam
pepper is that you don't be the court of
public opinion don't go on Twitter just
you know calling them a rapist or
calling that solves nothing that doesn't
do any constructive right you need to
think critically and honestly you need
to help your
and siblings and people think about it
critically and honestly and I think that
it's important to remember that just
because you don't like something doesn't
mean we can violate their liberties in
this country fair enough fair enough
and that as much as you know all of
these things on the internet make people
really upset we those things need to
exist so that everyone can have a voice
and that's what's so special about this
country is that everyone is allowed to
have a voice but sometimes it just takes
things like this to remind you like oh
yeah not everyone's here to play nice
and do things that are right there's
here two people here people here to [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and do whatever they want and
trample on that but it's what gives you
that right to speak your mind hmm yeah
you're right and maybe next time he
uploads a video about murdering his
mother just don't click on it you know
yeah I mean we like you it's important
that like I think your view is important
of like remembering what our rights are
but I don't necessarily agree with just
how you've spoken about him in this
situation I just you know we stand in
two different spots which is fine we're
both like you know we've often liked it
we both disagree with his choices and
the timing everything we but why I do
feel like we were in a little you know
were a little different you know points
in how we think of a [ __ ] what the
situation is and how it how it should be
handled and what should happen all the
all the hypotheticals you know but I
would you know I think it's important
that everyone has their own train of
thought
I know right and and you shouldn't let
us weigh you but for any reason if
you're a fan of Sam pepper I mean feel
free to leave a comment why you're a fan
of Sam peppers like what I think is
important about him being a human being
is that not all of the content that he
uploads is like this I know he deep
downside is probably a very nice person
and
I'm okay I imagine that for those people
that are fans of his he has done things
in the past to you know make them feel
things or think about things that he
means something to them and whether you
like it or not or whether you agree with
it or not there must be reasons why
people enjoy him that are not just like
oh he's really great at race and I've
heard from people who have had past
friendships with him saying there is
something in there that is a good guy
you are you know you're not wrong about
them there are the good qualities he is
not just the worst but um yeah you know
it's it in like you know I'm not the ten
person who's gonna hate someone forever
I I can hardly hold a grudge for like a
week on someone no matter what it is
like I like peace I like happiness so
you know hopefully some capacity some
small ounce of justice will come down on
him and then we can all move on and yeah
what will happen will happen we can move
on you know I mean there's no point you
know years from now to be hating Sam
pepper
it's like he's gonna he's going to do
what he's going to do hopefully justice
will be served in any sort of capacity
but you know we have to be able to move
on from things and we as the community
can decide not to work with them yeah we
we don't have to publicly trash him or
you know do any of that business yeah we
can just decide that he's not really a
part of our community that we're gonna
put up with or work with that's what we
have control over and you have control
over your you know siblings daughters
children whatever about what they're
consuming and why they're consuming it
and their thoughts about it and that's
about it and the rest of it you gotta
put your hands up and just let Sam
pepper do Sam pepper even if it makes
you mad absolutely yeah Tom well thanks
for tuning in this year's beginning him
I think he's a saturation that needed to
be had I haven't heard anybody have this
conversation you know
yeah really sort of think about it no
I'm just talking about it is helping
like just kind of understand my my
thoughts my feelings on it and just the
situation overall so hopefully you guys
gain something from yeah hearing this
talk and hopefully in the future because
he is not the first and will certainly
not be the last in the history of the
internet or
people let's do some sort of over the
line this is gonna happen and I think
that it's going to help us grow and
learn as people as students of the
Internet to understand what we shouldn't
shouldn't do in reaction and what we
shouldn't shouldn't do to police
ourselves in our community absolutely
hmm for sure I think it's a good talk
and a good thought conversation to have
so for the future we will be better
equipped to handle someone like this
when they're you know when it happens
yeah yeah doing this absolutely I think
that's true
thank you too texture yeah make sure you
check out extra free trial guys you have
to pay anything texture calm slash Jenna
Julianne magazines at your fingertips
curated saved for offline reading it's
amazing check them out
also me undies me undies that's Mei
undies calm / Jenna Julian 20 percent
off your first order of the most
comfortable underwear yeah yet in the
world you they will be doing this free
shipping in the US and Canada up on the
enemies but thanks to our sponsors thank
you to you guys we really really love
you guys and we appreciate every three
weeks you tune yeah we will see you guys
next week with definitely a happier
for sure